and it's sent deep into the Buffalo Zone
steel racing after it followed by pavelski
back to the line for the shot and Lucan
in with the save but the rebound right in
front of him clear to the wall here's Duane
Fanning on the shot comes back to him again
in the slot he'll play it back and Harley
bumps it to the right wall back in front and
Luc gets over in time to get a piece of that
one from Marchman du Shane with a shot score
to Shane's fourth power play goal of the Year
1602 remaining in the first it's one- nothing
stars but you see right here right behind the net
it pops out and the Quick Pass from the right to
the left you got duch Shane standing there and
he just slides in from the points got a clear
shot and it doesn't look like LC able to see
that one coming there's Johnson goes down it
goes right past kyoso holding that Puck and plays
it up ahead Do's gone to the front of the net but
the puck stays on the wall now it's up top KY
of posal high slot shot stopped by out Ander
Skinner hanging around for a rebound now down to
the goal line here's a shot by Thompson stopped
by AER over on the right wing wall centers that
one goes off the skate at Clifton Savers get a
break there good positioning in front of the
net you Le that tonight against this Dallas
team here's cousins far Circle shot oer with
a save turn over behind the net Benson walks
out in front Another Chance backand by Peto wi
full time and here's penson with a wraparound
tries to stuff it in all three guys converging
down cousins there petk on the backand that's
it cuz he picks it off he's in the right place
run over as he played that puck back towards the
front of the net a bouncing Puck Pon off laid
off that one as did Craig Smith now here's a
lead pass with a breakway back hand stopped to
Skinner puts this over the top of the net Owen
power with an excellent pass to Jeff skry just
not able to get it NHL upstairs that I see what
we're doing we're deflecting blaming them yes of
course here's Middle St nice pass across and AER
gets there to make the save we'll just take a
look here great opportunity watch Casey middle
stats pass across to dolene he steps in and he's
one-on-one with ainger but look at this pass by
Casey middlest stat and that Lane right there
is straight to ainger and the guy he want hin
Johnson and Robertson out for the stars with the
offensive zone face off one by Dallas Lucan gets
a pat on the shot from the point Robertson gets
it in front to hits big save by Lucen now you're
right hence is one of the best young players right
now in the quick face to face right there and you
see him come out he's attacking not sitting back
in the net getting out being aggressive see the
good push off there and makes the save but plays
it now it's Tage Thompson into the Dallas Zone
spins it for petka with a shot had save it for
Thompson oh my goodness ottinger able to make
the stop far Circle one timer and ottinger got
a piece of that one Mighty going off the Stick
of the defenseman in front of the net here
is dolene up top Thompson fire [Applause]
[Applause] scores and it's that rocket shot
but they just kept firing they didn't waste
time passing around they established the shot and
I think that's what kind of broke down Dallas a
little bit right there and then they're a little
bit tired and then darene with a perfect pass to
takes Thompson right there along the circle and
boom he lets it ride and ottinger not able to get
the Blocker on that one and goes short side right
up in the top corner to tie this game with 1408
here's to Shane for Dallas at Center delene and
Skinner pick up the assists Sabers with cousins
up the middle takes the pass in behind the defense
with with a shot and AER up to challenge def Flex
it out of play coming right up the middle there's
the feed and he takes a quick look he knows he's
going to be under pressure looking to go far side
on ainger and it just kind of hits him right in
the shoulder and up and over the glass Sabers
could Sabres find some space pass too far for
Skinner steel plays it to the middle of the
ice and the stars on the counter with a shot
and lucan's got it rebound squirts in behind him
Stars take a 2-1 lead yeah Pasa just throws this
one to the front of the net and it bounces in
off something in front and here everybody's in
good shape right here everything's the outside
it's a high shot lucing not able to handle it
and it drops FASA just turns and fires this
one to the front of the net and you see steel
right there 18 in the blue paint as he fires it
across goes right off his right skate and into the
net
[Music] yeah that shot just high on
the right shoulder Benson turns tries
to dance his way to a shooting Lane
but it's not there he'll keep it down
low Ryan sh at Benson one one wither who makes
a stop right in front of the net Ryan Johnson
here on the back end he's going to find Benson
wide open in front starts G it back and to end
we go here another potential two-on-one in
front of the net holding it Lucan and makes
the stop but a big save it is and down and
off right at the end one-on-one with lukan
and tries to go short side doen being watched by
Steel high in the zone middle stat left side in
front Alex tuck and that puck goes to the corner
but here's Alex tuck all by himself in front and
pops up and over the right shoulder of oer and
off into the corner Dyan cousins ahead bka makes
the turn right side moving his feet down to the
corner trying to drive off the defender he does
up front for cousins in the onetime ottinger
made the stop opportunities here's another one
this is petker going to find cousins right in
the middle and he lets it go one times you see
aggressive D Shane open the scor hinan to Shane
top of the circle working it down though pelski
stopped by Lucan in the rebound duain takes it to
the cornerboard up top for hinan in front of the
net right here the other one was henan who was
taking the shot doen to cousins carries in over
the line right down the middle nice tangle in the
back hand stopped by tinger in The Rebound tinger
in the trapazoid behind the net will cover up
and hold on trailing Dallas by a score of two to
one Tage Thompson turns it up trying to feed it
through for dolene last man back can't get it
back here's a chance LC in with the save there
and Wyatt Johnson to the rebound Sabers able
to get out to Center Ice the done off with this
one-on-one against Lucan and watch Lucan as he
sticks that Walker low and out on toov and makes
the stop AR big save brought to by Toyota Let's Go
Roberts shot as Lucan came out to challenge comes
out The Far Side hint plays it right onto the
stick on the counter and it's a chance here for d
cousin holds it stop made by AER he came well out
to challenge cousins goes back in Dylan cousins
earlier as soon as this P to kill started he got
his wheels going he got in D in behind the ne gets
the puck it puts it off the Boors but the Shane
will trap it out of the box is Yoki Haru it's a
five on four save made by Lucan and rebound oh
my goodness what a save by Lucan and he lost the
stick on the play but he gets it back from Rasmus
dolene right away yeah right here in front you got
duchaine and he just stick to stick with power 126
that pass outside the line now 123 remaining in
the power play for the Stars 209 to go in the
period Sabers Trail by a goal to Shane in for hits
and a pat save by Lucan again clearing attempt
gets outside the line Sabers win it back to Dalene
Tes Thompson well out from the net up top delene
Thompson right Circle passed across for the shot
oer got over to make the save he cotton you're
beat into the punch yeah that's a real good look
there just going D to D with Thompson and darene
on the top just doing it a couple times and then
Thompson finding middle 7 Seconds to go darene
with a shot it bounces just wide off traffic in
front Savers trying to center it again and that'll
do it oh they come so close the Stars will get out
of town here with a win that they could consider